Bonjour, vous regardez un court métrage
au format vertical
qui se regarde sur un smartphone.
Donc si vous avez lancé cette vidéo
sur votre ordinateur ou votre télé,
vous pouvez basculer
sur votre téléphone
et mettre la vidéo en plein écran
avec le petit bouton en bas à droite.
Est-ce que c'est bon ?
Je suis en plein écran ?
Alors bon visionnage.
Ah, voilà !
- Coucou.
- Bon anniversaire !
Merci papa, merci maman.
Alors j'imagine que t'as déjà
plein de copains
qui ton souhaité ton anniversaire.
Hé bien non car il est 7 heures du mat'
vous êtes les premiers.
Alors c'est la grosse fête ce soir ?
Pas vraiment puisque je suis né
en plein milieu d'août
et tous mes potes sont en vacances
mais j'ai l'habitude, ne vous
inquiétez pas.
Tu fais pas quand même une petite fête ?
30 ans, ça se fête, non ?
Non mais je vais le faire chez moi
sur Netflix
ce sera très bien, ne vous
inquiétez pas.
- Tout seul ?
- Enfin !
Laisse-le faire comme il veut.
Mais c'est quoi ce truc ?
Je sais pas...
C'est toi, t'as du encore
toucher à un truc.
T'es gonflé, c'est toi qui tient
le téléphone.
C'est un filtre, ne vous inquiétez pas.
Écoute, ça marche pas ce truc
je sais pas ce qu'il se passe.
Écoute, bonne journée.
Bon anniversaire mon grand !
Merci papa, merci maman.
Merci beaucoup pour ce cadeau !
Au début j'ai cru que
ça allait être une PS5
mais attend, ton compte Insta
c'est carrément mieux !
Merci beaucoup.
Ouais, j'étais peut-être alcoolisé,
c'est vrai.
C'est juste que ce soir, je...
C'est pas que je veux pas te voir.
Si d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien te voir, mais...
D'ailleurs il n'y a pas de mais,
c'est juste que...
Putain, ça me saoule...
Carrément, tu peux passer !
Bien sûr.
Il y a une teuf avec mes potes
enfin, quelques potes.
Ça me ferait plaisir de te revoir.
Voilà, à ce soir !
Juste pour savoir, comme ça, les gars
qui est sur Paris ce soir ?
À tout hasard.
Putain...
Happy birthday Guigui !
From New York !
Appeler Paulo.
Salut, vous êtes bien sur
le répondeur de Paulo
Vous pouvez laisser un message
juste après le bip
- Tu viens Paulo ?
- Attend je...
Merde... Paulo, ouais.
Rappelle-moi dès que possible.
J'espère que t'es sur Paris.
On se voit ce soir alors !
Et je viendrai avec un truc pour
ambiancer les soirées
tu vas voir, mais il faut que je le
retrouve dans mon bordel.
À ce soir, bisous !
Envoyer un message à Paulo..
Que souhaitez-vous dire ?
Rappelle-moi, s'il-te-plaît.
D'accord, c'est envoyé.
Bon anniversaire Guillaume.
Merci, c'est gentil.
- 30 ans c'est ça ?
- Ouais, 30 ans.
- Ça file les années.
- Ouais.
Allez.
Dis-moi, tu...
Ce soir, toi tu... T'as un truc...
J'ai mon train pour La Rochelle.
T'as ton train pour La Rochelle.
OK, je comprends.
J'ai trop hâte.
Le boulot quand tout le monde
est en vacances...
T'as raison. Les vacances c'est bien.
Hé, salut mon gars !
Paulo, merci de me rappeler.
Bon anniversaire !
30 ans, mon gars, ça se fête.
Dis-moi, ce soir, toi tu...
Regarde, c'est ma cousine, elle se marie.
Coucou ! On se connait pas mais
bon anniversaire Guillaume !
On est à Perpignan, il fait
une chaleur mon pote !
Tu voulais me dire un truc ?
Non, juste merci, c'est gentil.
- J'ai du boulot.
- Bosse bien !
Faut que je te laisse, on va
faire la fête.
Salut ! Bisou !
Et c'est une excellente nouvelle !
Je l'ai retrouvé ! C'est tellement le bordel
dans mes tiroirs.
Bref, à tout à l'heure !
J'ai fait des petites provisions pour ce soir
donc il faut que tu me donnes ton adresse
à moins que tu sois un agent secret
et que ce soit totalement confidentiel
J'attends ! À tout de suite.
Joyeux anniversaire.
Joyeux anniversaire...
...tout seul.
Joyeux...
- Il va griller !
- Chut !
T'as fait faire un double des clés ?
J'ai le double des clés.
- Chut !
- On y va !
On dit "joyeux anniversaire".
Joyeux anniversaire !
Surprise !
C'est quoi ce bordel ?
T'étais en train de faire quoi là ?
Non rien. Vous, pourquoi vous êtes ici ?
Toi t'étais à la mer, toi
T'étais en train de te branler ?
Non non !
Pas du tout, j'étais...
Sors ! Sors !
- Laissez-moi une seconde !
- Allez !
Putain, vous êtes vraiment des bâtards...
- Il rappelle !
- Vas-y ! La mariée !
Excusez-moi ! On peut faire
comme on a dit !
Salut mon gars !
Paulo, merci de me rappeler.
Bon anniversaire, 30 ans mon gars
ça se fête !
Merci. Toi, ce soir, tu...
Regarde, c'est ma cousine, elle se marie !
Coucou !
Aucune idée.
Il y avait un mariage en bas de chez moi
donc j'ai pris une veste,
je lui ai demandé
de te souhaiter un joyeux anniversaire
Et... c'est tout.
C'est bon ?
C'est pas trop cramé que c'est
un bac à sable ?
Ça se voit pas ? On voit pas
les petits marrons ?
Et en fait pas du tout !
On est dans le quinzième.
On est bien  à Paris, comme il faut.
- Mais non !
- C'est une cuvette !
C'est une cuvette de chiotte.
C'est abusé ! J'y ai trop cru.
OK, je reviens dans une seconde.
Il va où ?
- Hé, ça va ?
- Ça va et toi ?
C'est qui ?
- C'est Clem.
- C'est Clem ?
Oh le bâtard !
J'ai trouvé ça dans mon placard.
Mais t'es venue comment ?
C'est Paulo qui m'a ajouté
sur Instagram.
Ah oui, il t'as filé l'adresse !
OK d'accord.
OK, vous êtes prêts ?
Oui !
Joyeux anniversaire !
Joyeux anniversaire Guigui !